>> Greg: WINNING.
WINNING IS SO DELICIOUS.
YES.
ALL RIGHT, HAPPY TUESDAY
AMERICA.
LET'S UPDATE YOU ON THE RAID ON
MAR-A-LAGO.
WE GOT NEVER-BEFORE-SEEN
FOOTAGE.
ROLL IT.
♪♪
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
DON'T CLAP.
SO LIKE PAUL PELOSI DRIVING DOWN
A 2-WAY STREET, PRETTY OBVIOUS
THAT MERRICK GARLAND CROSSED THE
LINE.
AND NOW THE MEDIA REALIZES THEIR
WHOLE NARRATIVE IS FALLING APART
LIKE A POT ROAST IN A HOT TUB.
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO THE STORY
ABOUT THE NUKES?
YEAH, APPARENTLY TRUMP STOLE
VALUABLE NUCLEAR SECRETS HE WAS
PLANNING TO SELL TO SOMEONE.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU, BUT THIS
SEEMS LIKE A STRANGE CAREER
TRANSITION FOR A REAL ESTATE
TYCOON.
SHOULD I BUILD A NEW LUXURY
CONDOMINIUM DEVELOPMENT IN
MIDTOWN OR SELL NUCLEAR SECRETS
TO PUTIN?
IT'S A TOUGH CALL.
ON ONE HAND YOU COULD MAKE A LOT
OF MONEY LEGALLY.
ON THE OTHER, YOU COULD BE
EXECUTED FOR TREASON.
OF COURSE, THE MEDIA ALWAYS
PICKS THE MOST ABSURD CRAP TO
PEDDLE ABOUT TRUMP.
SO WHAT'S THE MEDIA WHO INVESTED
SO MUCH IN THE SIGH COMPANIES IS
NOW.
THEY SAY IF YOU CRITICIZE THE
RAID YOU'RE INCITING VIOLENCE
AGAINST THE FBI WHO IS DOING THE
LOURDES WORK OF SNIFFING
MELANIA'S SHOES.
I CHOSE THE WORD SHOES.
AND TRUE THERE WERE NOTABLE
INSIGHTMENTS TO VIOLENCE.
THERE WERE.
REMEMBER MICHAEL TWEETED A PHOTO
OF THE ROSENBERGS WHO WERE
EXECUTED FOR SELLING NUCLEAR
SECRETS TO MOSCOW?
IT WAS A TWEET THAT GENERAL
MICHAEL HAYDEN CONCURRED WITH BY
ADDING, SOUNDS ABOUT RIGHT.
THAT'S TWO MAJOR VOICES NOT
CALLING OUT THE FBI BUT
SUGGESTING THE EXECUTION OF
TRUMP.
BUT THE MEDIA IGNORES THAT
INCITEMENT, PREFERRING TO CALL
OUT RANDOM NUT JOBS POSTING
THREATS ON MESSAGE BOARDS.
BUT I GET IT.
YOU SHOULD SEE THE STUFF I POST
ON THE MY LITTLE PONY FORUMS.
BUT IF YOU EVER MESS WITH
TWILIGHT SPARKLE, I'LL [BLEEP]
KILL YOU.
BUT, LET'S SAN DER OVER TO CNN
WHERE WOLF BLITZER THE UGLIEST
OF SANTA'S REINDEER INTERVIEWED
ADAM KINZINGER WHOSE LAST NAME
IN GERMAN MEANS I CRY DURING
TAMPON COMMERCIALS AND WOLF ASKS
THE MOST LEADING QUESTION YOU
COULD POSSIBLY ASK, AND, NO, IT
WASN'T WILL YOU MARRY ME.
ROLL IT.
>> YOU'VE SEEN THIS JOINT FBI
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
BULLETIN NOW WARNING OF WHAT
THEY CALL UNPRECEDENTED VIOLENT
THREATS IN THE WAKE OF THE
SEARCH OF MAR-A-LAGO.
DO YOU HOLD THE FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP RESPONSIBLE FOR
INCITING HIS SUPPORTERS?
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY, A HUNDRED
PERCENT WOLF.
ANY REPUBLICAN ELECTED OFFICIAL
OUT THERE THAT RUSHES TO BE THE
FIRST ON TELEVISION OR THE FIRST
TO TWITTER TO BASICALLY CONDEMN
THE FBI, THIS STOKES THAT.
IT'S REALLY DANGEROUS, AND I
FEAR IT COULD GET WORSE.
>> Greg: OH, IT COULD GET WORSE
HE FEARS.
OR HOPES.
BUT THIS IS NOT JOURNALISM, THIS
IS EMOTIONAL PROPAGANDA IN WHICH
THE HOST INDULGES THE DAMAGED
PSYCHE OF HIS GUESTS.
IT'S MORE MANIPULATIVE THAN FOX
RUNNING PIZZA COMMERCIALS DURING
MY HANGOVER.
SO IF YOU CONDEMN THE RAID,
YOU'RE STOKING VIOLENCE, AS
OPPOSED TO BEST LOSS OF HAYDEN
ACTUALLY SUGGESTING TRUMP IS
ELIGIBLE FOR EXECUTION.
BUT WHO KNOWS MORE ABOUT STOKING
VIOLENCE THAN CNN WHO HAVE BEEN
DENIGRATING COPS EVERY CHANCE
THEY GET FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS.
YET IT'S TRUMP'S FAULT FOR
INCITING VIOLENCE BECAUSE HE HAD
SOMEHOW INVITED THE RAID.
WHICH COULD BE THE DUMBEST THING
YOU EVER HEARD THAT DIDN'T COME
OUT OF DON LEMON'S MOUTH.
EVEN A CLOD LIKE ADAM KNOWS IT
WAS THE RAID THAT PISSED THEM
OFF.
THERE WAS NO INCITEMENT
NECESSARY BUT HE'S LOST IN THE
RABBIT HOLE OF ANTI TRUMP MANIA.
BUT THEN WHEN TRUMP TRIES TO
CLUE THE HEAT, LISTEN TO WOLF'S
QUESTION AND THEN THE ANSWER
FROM KINZINGER.
>> DOES IT STRIKE YOU AS ODD
THAT THE MAN WHO ACTUALLY SET
THE FIRE APPARENTLY TRIED TO ASK
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO PUT IT
OUT?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, IT'S A CREEPY
MESSAGE TO BE HONEST WITH YOU
JUST LIKE FRANKLY DONALD TRUMP
AND HIS SUPPORTERS HAVE BECOME
CREEPY IN HOW THEY'RE ACTING AND
WHAT THEY'RE THREATENING.
>> Greg: YEAH, WHEN ADAM CALLS
SOMEONE CREEPY IT FEELS LIKE
PROJECTION BECAUSE ABSOLUTELY
THERE'S NOTHING CREEPY ABOUT A
GROWN MAN WHO CRIES MORE THAN A
COL I CAN BABY WITH DIAPER RASH.
BUT IT'S NOT TRUMP PAINTING
TARGETS ON PEOPLE BUT PEOPLE
LIKE KINZINGER WHO HAVE BEEN A
WRECK SINCE TRUMP HIT THE
POLITICAL SCENE.
AMBER HEARD HASN'T CRIED AS MUCH
SINCE SHE MET JOHNNY DEPP.
IT GETS WORSE, IT GETS WORSE.
WHEN WOLF ASKS ABOUT LIZ CHENEY,
THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE POSSIBLY
LOSING THE GOP PRIMARY HE SAID
THIS.
>> I THINK IT SHOWS THAT THE
PARTY'S IN A BAD PLACE.
LOOK, WE ARE STANDING UP AGAINST
EVIL.
LIZ CHENEY IS STANDING UP
AGAINST EVIL.
AND I SAY THIS.
I PUT OUT THIS MESSAGE THE OTHER
DAY WHICH IS, A LOT OF PEOPLE
SIT AROUND AND DREAM ABOUT THE
DAY THEY GET TO DO IT AND VERY
FEW PEOPLE EVER GET THE CHANCE
TO REALLY STAND UP AGAINST EVIL.
>> YEAH, THEY'RE FIGHTING EVIL.
WHAT EVIL IS THAT EXACTLY?
IS IT TERRORISTS?
IS IT PEDOPHILES?
IS IT FIELD GOAL KICKERS?
NO, IT'S YOU.
IF YOU SUPPORT TRUMP YOU ARE
EVIL.
IF YOU DON'T TRUST THE
GOVERNMENT YOU'RE EVIL.
IF YOU DON'T TRUST THE MEDIA
YOU'RE EVIL.
IF YOU THINK THE FBI OR DOJ HAVE
FOLKS IN TOP POSITIONS WHO MAKE
POLITICAL DECISIONS INSTEAD OF
PRINCIPLED ONES YOU'RE EVIL.
MEANWHILE IF YOU'RE A BLACK
LIVES MATTER RIOTER A PERVERT
TEACHER OR THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT, NOTHING TO SEE HERE
FOLKS.
SO WHO'S PAINTING TARGETS ON
PEOPLE'S BACKS?
IT'S ADAM.
HE'S SHERWIN [BLEEP] WILLIAMS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: REMEMBER, IN ORDER TO
INSIGHT VIOLENCE AGAINST PEOPLE,
YOU HAVE TO DEHUMANIZE THEM.
IT'S AN OLD TACTIC THAT CHARLES
CROWD HAMMER STATED DECADES AGO,
THE RIGHT THINKS THE LEFT IS
WRONG, BUT THE LEFT THINKS THE
RIGHT IS EVIL.
WHAT'S FUNNY IS NORMALLY TO THE
LEFT LIZ CHENEY WOULD BE THE
EVILIST OF EVILS.
BUT HOW QUICKLY THE LEFT
FORGETS.
ADAM ISN'T A LEFTY BUT IS
ENJOYING THE STRANGE NEW RESPECT
GIVEN FROM THE LEFT.
HE'S LIKE A MARRIED MAN GETTING
HIT ON BY AN ATTRACTIVE STRANGER
EXCEPT THE ATTRACTIVE STRANGER
IS A NAMED WOLF AND HAS BREATH
THAT WREAKS OF POLLY GRIP.
THE LIBS GETTING STEERING THE
EMOTIONALLY DAMAGED ADAM TOWARD
CONCLUSIONS NO OBJECTIVE
REPUBLICAN WOULD EVER AGREE O
THEY'VE EXPLOITED HIS ANTI TRUMP
MANIA TO THEIR ADVANTAGE.
BECAUSE EVERYWHERE HE GOES,
WHICH IS BASICALLY CABLE NEWS
AND TWITTER, ALL THIS FEES ARE
RED HOT.
HE HAS LONG TRUMP DERANGEMENT
AND THERE'S NO VACCINE.
BUT IT'S GIVEN HIM AND CHEYNEY
BOTH A VICTIM AND HERO COMPLEX.
THEY'RE HEROES FOR FIGHTING EVIL
AND VICTIMS WHEN PEOPLE CALL OUT
THEIR BS.
AND WITH THAT THEY FORGET THE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
LIKE WHAT TRUMP DID AS
PRESIDENT.
THEY JUST AREN'T AS EMOTIONALLY
TIDE TO TRUMP'S PERSONALITY AS
THESE BRATS ARE.
SO WILL LIZ WIN OR LOSE.
DEPLETED FOR DEMS TO SWITCH
PARTIES TO HELP HER AND GOT A
LATE ENDORSEMENT FROM FREDDY
KRUGER.
PLUS SHE STILL HAS SOME PRETTY
BIG FANS.
>> LIZ CHENEY STANDS UP FOR THE
TRUTH.
AND THAT'S GOTTEN HER A LOT OF
HEAT.
SHE MAY LOSE HER POSITION IN THE
PARTY.
SHE MAY EVEN LOSE HER CAREER AS
A POLITICIAN.
BUT THAT IS SOMETHING TO BE
ADMIRED, STANDING UP FOR THE
TRUTH.
RIGHT NOW I'M KIND OF A FAN OF
LIZ CHENEY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: OJ CLAIMS HE'S A FAN.
AND IT MAKES SENSE.
THEY DO HAVE SOMETHING IN
COMMON.
ALTHOUGH OJ STABS PEOPLE IN THE
FRONT.
WHOA!
♪
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HE'S SO WHITE HE WEARS
SUN BLOCK AT NIGHT, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR TOM SHILLUE.
HE FILLED THE HOLE IN MY HEART
AND CREATED ONE IN BIN LADEN'S
HEAD.
FORMER NAVY SEAL AND HOST OF THE
PODCAST THE OPERATOR ROB
O'NEILL!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HE'S FAMOUS FOR HIS
COLUMNS, FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR ANDREW McCARTHY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: AND SHE'S LIKE YOUR
PHONE SCREEN, BRIGHT,
ILLUMINATING AND COVERED IN
GERMS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
I'VE GOT TO COME TO YOU FIRST
ANDY BECAUSE YOU'RE KIND OF LIKE
THE EXPERT IN THIS ASIDE FROM
ME, OF COURSE.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE PROS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS JOINT
BULLETIN?
TO ME IT SOUNDS EXACTLY LIKE THE
MEMO ABOUT DOMESTIC TERROR
EFFORTS BEING PARENTS, YOU KNOW?
>> Andy: THE JOINT ON --
>> Greg: ON -- WHAT DID HE CALL
IT?
THE UNPRECEDENTED THREATS
AGAINST THE FBI.
>> Andy: YOU KNOW, I JUST THINK
THEY'RE IN A TERRIBLE PLACE
RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW, THE THREATS OBVIOUSLY
ARE WHAT THEY INTERPRET TO BE
THREATS, ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TROUBLED BY WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
RAID AND, YOU KNOW, THE FACT
THAT THEY'RE GIVEN ONE STORY
ABOUT WHAT IT'S ABOUT, AND THEN,
YOU KNOW, THEY GET A LOOK AT THE
WARRANT AND IT TURNS OUT THAT
THE -- TO BE ABOUT SOMETHING
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
SO I THINK WHEN PEOPLE PROTEST,
THEY WANT TO REGARD IT OR THEY
WANT TO PORTRAY IT AS IF IT WERE
A THREAT OF VIOLENCE.
AND IN THE MEANTIME, IF YOU WANT
TO SEE WHO'S BEEN CRITICAL OF
THE FBI, YOU WOULD LOOK AT THE
HUNDREDS OF PAGES OF REPORTS
THAT HAVE BEEN WRITTEN BY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S OWN
INSPECTOR GENERAL WHO WORKS FOR
MERRICK GARLAND.
MAYBE GO DOWN ON THE HALL AND
KNOCK ON HIS DOOR.
>> Greg: ARE YOU SAYING HE IS A
TERRORIST?
>> Andy: COULD BE.
>> Greg: THAT'S THE POINT
THERE'S PEOPLE WITHIN THE FBI,
THE DOJ, WHO ARE HYPER CRITICAL,
TOM, I DO THINK YOU'RE EVIL.
>> Tom: ME?
>> Greg: YES.
YOU ARE EVIL.
IN THIS CASE I'LL MAKE AN
EXCEPTION.
YOU SHOULD BE DEMONIZED.
>> Tom: YOU KNOW WHAT I CAN'T
STAND?
IT'S THE PHONEY INDIG NANCE
COMING OUT OF THE LEADERSHIP AND
THAT'S WHO EVERYONE IS
CRITICIZING INCLUDING PEOPLE
LIKE YOU OR PEOPLE LIKE ME WHEN
I'M ON SHOWS LIKE FOX NEWS WHAT
DO I SAY?
I DON'T LIKE THE LEADERSHIP I
DON'T LIKE WHAT MERRICK GARLAND
HAS DONE, I DON'T LIKE WHAT
CHRISTOPHER WRAY HAS DONE AND
HOW THEY WON'T STAND UP.
THEY WON'T, YOU KNOW, HAVE THE
COURAGE OF THEIR CONVICTIONS AND
SAY WHAT'S IN THE WARRANT AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
SO WE CRITICIZE THE LEADERSHIP
AND THEN WE SAY, OH, I THINK
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT MY AGENT.
NO, ACTUALLY I'M TALKING ABOUT
YOU.
WAIT UNTIL MY AGENTS HEAR WHAT
YOU SAID ABOUT THEM.
>> NO, WE DON'T LIKE THE
LEADERSHIP.
>> HOW DARE YOU INSULT THE RANK
AND FILE.
THEY NEVER STOP WITH THAT AND WE
DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
INDIVIDUAL -- WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW.
WE ASSUME THE AGENTS ARE DOING
WHAT THEY'RE TOLD.
PLUS WE LIKE COPS AND FIREMEN.
YOU RIGHT WINGERS, YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO SUPPORT LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WE STILL SUPPORT LAW
ENFORCEMENT, COPS, FIREMAN.
BUT IF YOU WEAR A SUIT INTO THE
FBI BUILDING, YOU'RE NOT, YOU
KNOW, YOU'RE NOT LIKE A SOLDIER,
YOU'RE KIND OF IN AN OFFICE,
YOU'RE WAY DOWN THE LIST.
COPS, FIREMEN, BASICALLY ALL THE
VILLAGE PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, LIKE
INDIAN CHIEF, COWBOY,
CONSTRUCTION WORKER, THEN FBI
AGENT AFTER ALL THOSE SGHIES
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN WEIRD TO
HAVE FBI AGENT IN THE WELL
VILLAGE PEOPLE.
SO ROB YOU FOUGHT AND KILLED
EVIL.
SO WHEN YOU HEAR, I DON'T KNOW,
ADAM KINZINGER IS IN THE AIR
FORCE.
>> Rob: PILOT HE WAS A FRIEND OF
MINE
>> Greg: OH.
>> Rob: BELIEVE ME BEING IN THE
MILITARY WE CAN TAKE A LITTLE
BIT BUT I THINK WHAT HE'S DOING
HERE IS HE'S TAKING STUFF A
LITTLE TOO PERSONALLY.
HE'S IN THE SWAMP AND THE SWAMP
IS THEY'RE DEALING WITH PARTY
POLITICS.
THEY KNOW IF YOU CAN GET
SOMETHING TO SAY SOMETHING BAD
ABOUT TRUMP AND TRUMP SUPPORTERS
THEY'RE GOING TO DO WHAT THEY
CAN.
SURPRISED THEY HAD OJ UP THERE
BECAUSE I'M SURE WHAT HE SAID
RECENTLY IS THE SAME THING
SOMETHING WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
IT'S LIKE COMPARING A BATTERY TO
A FAT GIRL, LIKE IT'S GOING TO
HURT BUT I'M GOING TO PUT MY
TONGUE ON IT ANYWAY.
RIGHT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
THAT MEANS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THAT MEANS.
DON'T EXPLAIN IT TO ME.
I'D RATHER NOT KNOW.
>> Rob: BUT THEN YOU'VE GOT WITH
THE CHAINIES COMING OUT, THEY'RE
UPSET BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN IN
POLITICS FOREVER AND LIKE DICK
CHEYNEY SHOULDN'T BE UPSET ABOUT
ANYTHING BECAUSE HE'S STILL
ROLLING IN MILLIONS OF
HALIBURTON MONEY.
WE HAVE SOMETHING NOT IN COMMON
I FOUGHT IN THE WAR HE DODGED
THE DRAFT BUT WE DO HAVE
SOMETHING IN COMMON, WE BOTH
SHOT SOMEONE IN THE FACE.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
HUNTING ACCIDENT.
A HUNTING ACCIDENT.
SO, KAT, WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON
THIS INCREDIBLE STORY THAT JUST
DOESN'T SEEM TO END?
>> Kat: YEAH.
I CAN'T HANDLE ALL OF THE PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT LIZ CHENEY AS THIS
CHAMPION FOR THE TRUTH.
I'M LIKE, YOU MEAN THE PRINCESS
OF THE IRAQ WAR?
LIKE HER AND HER -- TRULY.
LIKE HER DAD, OF COURSE.
BUT ALSO SHE PROMULGATING THESE
LIES THAT LED TO A WAR, AND THEN
AFTER ALL OF THIS SHE'LL
PROBABLY GO WORK AT SOME WEAPONS
COMPANY, LIKE SOME COG IN THE
MILITARY INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX THAT
THOSE SAME LIES HELP BUILD UP.
SO I REALLY CAN'T HANDLE ANY OF
THE MORAL OUTRAGE.
>> Greg: THERE ARE TWO THINGS TO
THIS.
ONE, SHE WOULD BE CONSIDERED THE
MOST EVIL PERSON ON THE PLANET
BY THE SAME PEOPLE INTERVIEWING
HER NOW BUT NOW THAT SHE FITS
HER -- SHE PROVIDES A SERVICE,
WHICH IS ANTI TRUMP.
AND THEN TO YOUR POINT, IT
WAS -- IT WAS ABOUT TRUMP KIND
OF CLEANING HOUSE.
THE CHAINIES --
>> UH-HUH.
>> Greg: HE DIDN'T LIKE THE
CHAINIES.
>> I HAVE A THEORY ON THAT.
IT GOES FROM GEORGE BUSH TO, HE
WAS EIGHT YEARS AS
VICE-PRESIDENT, FOUR YEARS
PRESIDENT, GEORGE BUSH, CLINTON,
THE WHOLE FAMILY IN THERE AND IT
COMES BACK TO THE MILITARY
INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX.
I'M, IF YOU DON'T FOLLOW ON
TWITTER, I'LL SAY STUFF ABOUT
THEM BUT THEN THEY INVITE STUFF
LIKE THE ANYONE JA BOMB THAT CUT
INTO PIECES THAT'S DOPE.
THAT'S AWESOME.
>> Greg: IT IS.
I HAVE O